meanwhile ice is confirming that jose
rosales who is accused of killing harris
county texas corporal charles galloway
is in the country illegally when he
murdered that officer the professional
criminal has been on the run since 1996
he was wanted for another murder in el
salvador he was apprehended in mexico he
will appear before criminal court later
on this morning and you know you look at
the state of number of law enforcement
who are shot
why is that well
in in large measure it's because there
are a lot of guns but it's also because
there are not many consequences for
breaking the law and so it's like okay
i'm going to break the law
you know a cop's going to come over and
he's going to try to stop me and say you
know i'm not going to take it to a judge
because you're just going to get
released and so unless you know they
really feel trapped they feel like i can
get away with everything and
unfortunately too often they think that
but then they get in a squeeze
and they see a police officer and they
pull out a gun and it all hell breaks
loose my goodness that guy should not
even been out on the street no a
senseless murder and it could have been
prevented the number of officers
according to the fbi killed last year
highest recorded in the past 20 years
right you know it's pretty interesting
you know uh the disaster which is uh
portland uh they said okay if you guys
want to get hired back i know you're
retired we want to give you an incentive
to come back out of the 81 that retired
because they were getting no support
they were being defunded and defamed two
came back uh nobody wants the job
because they're not backed by the people
you don't become a cop because you want
to be rich or you want to be famous you
put your life on the line as we see too
you're not seeing people walk into a
middle of a gang war and you say well i
know that's dangerous these are some of
these things are normal traffic stops
and one of these police officers get
shot pulling somebody over because they
were speeding so there's no normal day
for a police officer and now that you
defamed them and defunded them and
diminished them and now you want them to
come back into your city and bring back
the law and order that they had a lot of
them throwing up their hands and saying
it's your problem now well joe biden's
coming to town coming up i believe
whatever thursday he's going to talk to
eric adams eric adams has a plan joe
biden's plan is no more guns you know
joe biden
sees the political reality of it the
defunding policing is
political poison so they're trying to
step away from that but at the same time
walk a fine line and not anger his base
meanwhile we've been showing you these
uh these pictures
of the migrants being released down on
our southern border in brownsville texas
bill molusion's team got a tip a couple
of days ago
apparently these releases of largely
young men remember we heard it was only
families and children and mothers who
who were being released those are all
guys that we can tell
these releases by the tens of thousands
have been going on ainsley since
february yeah that's exactly what one of
these ice agents told our reporters uh
didn't give his name but he said between
releases and the vaccine mandate the
morale is at the lowest imagine going to
the office to make phone calls all day
to coordinate travel for someone who
just came in illegally some of them with
criminal records he goes on to say they
contact a family member of these
illegals they ask the family member to
pay for their plane ticket or pay for
their bus ticket to get to their their
family somewhere in the united states
and if the family decides they're not
going to pay then these ngos buy them
the tickets and then the ngos bill the
government which means you're paying for
it he goes on to say the mass releases
have been happening discreetly like you
said since february the reporting only
scratches the surface but you just
mentioned they're releasing people with
criminal records oh yeah misdemeanors
they release anyone with a misdemeanor
so
they say that's assault that's dui drug
possessions illegal re-entry the only
ones that they hold are those with
really serious crimes and felonies so
governor abbott sat down with maria
after his meeting with the attorney
generals in states all across our
country uh just keep in mind it's not
that president biden has a bad policy
his policies to have no policy and not
address it and not bring it up and no
one really asks him to a point where
he's got to address it and ever since
the bridge situation no other media
outlet really cares the new york post
has on the first four pages despite
what's happening with law enforcement
because it's that outrageous and that
exclusive and i think that's sad that
nobody else cares about what's happening
westchester airport that small airport
in pennsylvania or jacksonville florida
meanwhile uh governor abbott does not
have the luxury of ignoring this it's
overwhelming his huge state he's taking
out personal resources for operation
lone star for 10 000 of his uh troops to
go out and try to patrol the border
there's only so much he can do here he
is talking to maria
there is lawlessness in the united
states of america right now and it
starts at the top position in the
country it needs to stop and biden needs
to be held accountable for the
lawlessness he himself is causing it's
been reckless
dangerous and deadly we're going to be
asking the federal judge to
put sanctions on the byte administration
for not complying with the federal court
order and not complying with federal law
well when you're the federal government
you can kind of do whatever you want to
they figured out how to
selectively enforce the law that so
infuriates the governor of the great
state of texas as it does with the
attorney general the great state of
florida who met with him yesterday
here's ashley moody earlier on our
program
what we once thought was just them
failing to follow law you know federal
law requires that
obama did it trump did it that you
deport those he'll here illegally
committing crimes but now
now they're going a step beyond they're
building infrastructure and programs
totally outside the law to facilitate
illegal immigration it must be stopped
we will push back i wonder if ice if
they just do a mass boycott if no one
goes they already turned their back on
homeland security secretary because he's
an embarrassment to the nation but
wonder if ice just says uh my reputation
and i have to be able to sleep at night
i'm concerned about what's happening in
the country i know i don't want them to
quit their job but if they all decided
just not to do it then they would force
the administration to address it because
they gutted ice they don't let them do
anything and now they're travel agents
to make sure illegal immigrants get put
in your neighborhood imagine working for
the federal government and they're
essentially telling you to break the law
you need to every day these illegal
immigrants send them out to various
cities around the country that's what
they're having to do and don't talk
about it you're not allowed to talk
about it you're telling them don't
enforce the law which unfortunately and
now we have a police officer down in
texas who is dead at the hands of an
illegal just one other thing you know if
if you think it's okay that all these
people come into the country what about
the fact that they are bringing so much
tons and tons of killer drugs there was
enough fentanyl seized in texas to kill
220 million americans and you know what
a lot of people don't realize this but
fentanyl the thing that they lace the
drugs with you know people think i'm
just buying some pot
the fentanyl that is used for all those
things is the number one killer of
americans between 18 and 45. so much
emphasis on covet but look at this the
number one killer is fentanyl and it is
completely preventable if you stop the
fluid drugs across the scene the
majority comes across the border yeah i
just hope they're wearing masks as long
as they're wearing mess that'll be great
right so carl
i understand you have breaking news
i actually do this is a really important
story that's breaking right now we're
going to get to a fox news alert right
now police ems and firefighters are
responding to a bridge collapse in
pittsburgh several cars and a port
authority bus
with three people on board were
reportedly on the snow-covered bridge
when it collapsed but so far no injuries
have been reported officials say there
is still a quote strong smell of natural
gas in the area authorities are asking
locals to avoid this area and this comes
as the same day president biden is set
to tout his infrastructure deal in
pittsburgh